you know they people say how did you get
you know suburban women and how do you
get minorities and how do you get
democrats and
independents to vote for a republican uh
but i think it's one of the things that
the republican party is going to have to
think about how do we reach out to
a wider group of people in order to win
elections in the future and so we can be
in
in the position of making decisions
[Music]
do you think bottom line when you get
rid of all the other issues that you're
dealing with all day
that if you as a governor can keep the
economy chugging and keep people at work
that you've basically done your job
well we you know we're wrestling with
all kinds of really
tough issues dave when you're governor
of the state
as i mentioned you know we're dealing
with a you know close to a 50 billion
dollar budget and
you know 60 some thousand employees we
have to provide all these different
services there's so many different
issues
but really it is we're dealing with
educating folks and handling
transportation and
you know law enforcement all these
multitude of things
but the focus that brought everybody
together in our state that they could
agree on they could argue
about various uh you know different
issues but the one thing they all agreed
on was
the pocketbook issues and that's how i
put together i put a group together
called change maryland it was a
nonpartisan citizen organization
and we had just as many democrats and
independents as republicans
and they were just saying let's focus on
these issues
let's not argue about all these other
things right now let's just focus on
these and
uh we brought together a coalition it
turned out to be a winning coalition and
and uh you know people say how did you
get you know suburban women and how do
you get minorities and how do you get
democrats and independents to vote for
a republican uh but i think it's one of
the things that
the republican party is going to have to
think about how do we reach out to
a wider group of people in order to win
elections in the future and
so we can be in in the position of
making decisions
yeah so i want to get more to that and
the the sort of pure political side in a
minute but
let's talk about what's what i didn't
mean to get too political on you dave
a governor getting political i can't
believe it uh yeah let's not do that
anymore
yeah yeah let's let's talk about what's
going on now though because
uh you know there's been i think the
major conversation really
um at a high level is sort of what the
federal government is supposed to do
related to coronavirus and what the
state governments are supposed to do
i suspect i generally know your thoughts
on this but but what do you think
your job as a governor is right now and
what is not your job what is the job of
the federal government
that's a great question look i i think
the governors are on the front lines of
this crisis and
and we ought to be we're we are out
there we're closest to the people's
problems we're working together with our
our local governments and we're trying
to really address these issues that are
on the ground in our individual states
and
each of our states are different we're
going after you know
the different uh situations on the
ground in our states
but there was there was a major there
were certain big things that only the
federal government could do well
so you know early on in this crisis
the federal government could have taken
more of a role in an overall
testing strategy they did you know they
were a little bit i think behind the
eight ball on
in the early stages and i talked about
this in my book a little bit in march
and april
when they weren't taking it as seriously
i mean there were people in the
administration who were
i think the president downplayed it a
little more than he should have
and they didn't develop a lot of
national strategies
we had 50 individual state strategies
i'm not saying
states shouldn't have had the authority
and independence to be able to make
their own decisions but
certain things like we shouldn't have 50
states competing with one another
in a constrained market for desperately
needed supplies competing with the
federal government and trying to
you know acquire things all over the
world so on testing and contact tracing
and some of the major issues that the
power of the federal government could
really have helped
with the pandemic and in some respects
they're getting better
but certain things the federal
government can just do better
can you talk a little bit about how you
specifically make
decisions when it comes to lockdown or
the rest of it because as you know i'm
here in los angeles california
we've had rolling lockdowns then they
kicked in again last week i was actually
out to lunch for the first time in weeks
and as
i was having lunch we got the the
notification on my phone that said the
restaurants
are closing in two hours now
everything's closed again
and i've been very critical of gavin
newsom our governor here
not necessarily because of what he's
doing rather than the messaging
it seems like they just they just give
edicts they never say well we've seen
these numbers change this way
we know this behavior changed this or
that it's just oh
now we're locking down we'll see you in
august we'll see in september
and and that's what i'm sort of more
concerned about can you talk a little
bit about how you message things and how
you actually
come to the decisions yeah it was great
question dave and you hit on a couple of
really good points first of all i agree
that the messaging has been a problem on
be you know i think a lot of the
governors are not
messaging very well and frankly i think
that's where the pr
president's biggest biggest weaknesses
have been on the messaging side
um i've tried to be just very direct and
upfront and provide as much information
as possible because i think most people
whether the the news is good or bad if
you're if you're just
you know frank with them and you supply
the facts in a situation like this when
we're dealing with
you know in some cases life and death
matters in a serious health crisis and a
global pandemic and economic
collapse potentially people want to know
the facts and they want to know why
you're making decisions so
you know i think i'm not the only one
doing it but their number the governors
who have been more direct and open and
transparent i think i've been the most
successful on the decision-making
process
i just tried to get um you know we had
to make decisions
really quickly in this thing because it
wasn't like we have
deliberations with our legislature and
let's talk about it and form a committee
you know this was happening really fast
at the beginning as we were spiking we
were seeing things happening in italy
and new york and
people dying and bodies stacked up and
overflowing hospitals and
we were hearing these things about two
million potential deaths and
so we were it was speed time it was of
the essence to make some decisions
um you had to make the right decisions
quickly you couldn't hesitate
but i wanted to get the best advice i
could from the smartest people
we put together a task force of really
smart doctors and scientists and
business people
and and i just tried to get the best
input listen to everyone and then
make decisions without hesitating and
then communicate it really well to the
people about
this is what we're doing and here's why
and here's how it's going to help
and so we took very aggressive and early
actions
did things that i never would have
imagined ever doing but it helped us
flatten the curve i mean our numbers are
really good our economy is really good
we took early and aggressive action we
had a safe and effective reopening
and uh you know we're now you know way
down from our peak that happened about
more than 90 days ago
we've opened up 98 of our economy and
our unemployment at eight percent is
staggering but it's it's you know some
states are two and a half times worse
better than the rest of the country um
and um and our numbers
well you know we we've had a number of
deaths and
we had the same problems other people
had we're in great shape right now
yeah on a personal note as a guy that
didn't want to always get into politics
when you have to make those decisions
about okay we're going to extend the
lockdown we're going to lift the lock
down whatever it may be
um wha what's that like for you because
i think people think
people think of politicians sort of as
robots like oh they just make the
choices
but yeah no it was really really hard
dave it's
you know i've been through and i talk
about some of these you know personal
and professional struggles
and battles that i've been through in my
book and i share some of that you know
what it was like and
and all the things that i had to deal
with on a personal level or what battles
i
went through as governor or getting
elected governor
this was the hardest thing that i think
i've had to deal with um
something we never imagined dealing with
and it wasn't just you know i went
through a cancer battle where i was
worried about
how my family was going to take it or
you know what what was
i was dealing with other cancer patients
but this was i was worried about 6
million people in my state and
my decisions were going to impact not
only their health but i'm a lifelong
small business guy ran for governor with
the sole purpose
of creating jobs and helping small
businesses and decisions i was going to
make were going to impact
was going to cost people jobs and hurt
their small businesses or people were
going to die
um it it was a really hard situation to
be put in
and and frankly the president um senator
left it up he said it's up to the
governors
and we were getting you know um you know
open up
and then you know but you have to shut
down he was given the the administration
was giving us advice you have to do
these things
or we're gonna have two million deaths
and then uh you know messaging the
opposite stuff
the next day so it was we were in tough
situations but i think and everybody
made different decisions but
uh on a personal level i mean it's
there's been very little sleep
for five months and a lot of stress and
you got people that are mad at you
either way no matter what you do
you can't make everybody happy and you
know i just tried to do the very best i
could
based on the information i had and um
you know try to do the best thing for
for the people in the state yeah so
let's talk about the other
thing that's going on because there is
another thing going on there's always a
lot of things but there's sort of two
main ones going on at the moment and and
the second one obviously
is i guess the best way you you describe
it
is either the racial unrest or the
protesting or the rioting just the whole
conversation we're having the
the toppling of of monuments now again
you're in maryland
dc's right there awful lot of monuments
awful lot of history is right in your
backyard
um you know you've got you've got
baltimore there which has its own set of
set of problems
um so i'm not even going to ask you a
question i'm just going to i'm going to
just pass all that off to you
take it away yeah yeah well that was
that's we're just going to let me tee it
up and
um what so i i you know you look at the
title of the book it's like
riots you know cancer riots a global
pandemic
i i dealt with this and i talk about
this a lot and there's real parallels to
what's going on right now with the
the riots the the violence the the
unrest the protests
uh what however you want to describe
there's a little bit of all of that
going on across america in different
cities
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell